alors emmanuelle seigner re bonsoir
bonsoir alors toute la semaine vos
attaché de presse c'est à dire ceux du
film et puis vous attaché de presse
personnel m'ont téléphoné en me disant
que vous aviez peur de devenir dans
cette émission ce soir pourquoi parce
que vous avez peur de perdre votre
mystère en en bien du tout c'est que
vous aimez bien torturé les gens ah oui
mais pas les tv est ce que ça fait de
l'audimat et j'ai pas envie d'être une
de vos victimes ouais vous avez peur de
moi j'ai pas peur de vous mais j'ai
envie de me servir de vous mais je veux
pas que vous vous serviez de moi
cérébrale
on va faire une question votre chat très
très gentil vous préférez quand vous
confondre avec mathilde seigner ou avec
ludivine sagnier
avec personne est-ce que vous avez
préféré être la belle soeur de laurent
gerra ou de à anthony delon non je
réponds pas à ces questions ah bon
pourquoi pas ce que c'est ça m'intéresse
pas ah bon voilà
bien la ville qui était drôle là allez-y
banon voulait pas réprimé en malaisie
j'écoute mais non mais si vous répondez
pas je vais pas vous dire que j'ai une
va répondre
mais je vous la pose oui vous êtes pas
me dire qu'elle est bête après six mois
c'est moi que vous torturer ouais ah
ouais les rôles seront pas changés à
verser 1 dire si oui ou non je vais
simplement savoir faisait déjà couché
avec votre mari pour avoir un rôle
mais là je rêve quoi je rêve là vous
vous sentez éminemment supérieur d'un
coup nos supérieurs de quoi de vous
non je trouve ça vraiment stupide quoi
vous avez pas vous épanouir quand même
non
ne vais pas pleurer pourquoi je suis
venu pour défendre le film dans lequel
je suis d'accord ça aurait été dommage
effectivement vous veniez pas parce que
vous êtes excellente dans le fil
c'est vrai c'est rare de voir dans un
rôle comme olic qui m'a fait peur
j'ai cru qu'elle est assez rare de voire
excellentes mais là il faut
réparer l'ambiance qui est très dégradé
alors c'est vrai c'est assez inattendu
de quoi de mordre dans un rôle comique
oui c'est vrai que yvan à une bonne idée
encore c'est yvan non mais je pense que
pour vous c'est un film aussi important
que place vendôme parce que sur la place
vendôme ça vous a révélé un petit peu et
ce film va être à mon avis aussi
important oui je pense mais en même
temps je pense que j'ai j'ai fait
du très bon travail dans frantic ou dans
lunes de fiel mais quand c'est mis en
scène par roman polanski
les gens et surtout les critiques ne
voit pas ça ils voient pas le travail
ils jugent comme une commune femmes et
pas comme une actrice et donc voila quoi
mais ça va ouais ça va
il faut savoir moi ça va très bien je
vous faire une interview complexe
d'actrice au nom non
pourquoi
[Musique]
essayons essayons emmanuelle seigner est
ce que vous êtes et je n'ai pas non non
non non mais je suis je me dis oui je
suis gêné pour emmanuel parce que je
l'assemblée je la sens pas tranquille
quoi même moi ça me crispe ah ouais mais
aussi en matière
d'industrie angie vous êtes crispé
et pourtant à part le patron s'est tu
pour te dire une sale ambiance
ça commence fort
c'est à toi d'instaurer un climat de
sympathie de convivialité c'est ton
travail qui rit oui bah là j'essaye ah
ouais vas-y on l'a fait c'est une
interview pas non non vous les affaires
vous
oui mais je passe dans le fond
voulait pas la faire pourquoi vous savez
même pas ce que c'est non mais j'aime
pas trop c'est qu'ils interviewent là
ça vous plaît pas ça
qu'est ce qu'on fait mais aussi des
émissions qui commençait mal et qui se
terminait bien les invités non mais
j'adore il peut y avoir aussi un
renversement de situation vraiment peut
partir sur une super bonne impression
aussi mettons ça dans un coin de notre
tête c'est pas impossible mais c'est mal
barré mais c'est pareil
on n'en est pas là
tout à l'heure je la met là et puis si
vous la sentez en leurs deux trois ans
toute façon la
bâtisse ne bougera pas on va laisser
cela ici voilà c'est pour vous
bon ben on passe à angie alors jamais
notre fiche de côté pour alger parce
qu'elle ne fera pas non plus mais
alors angie david breux bonsoir donc
dans le film c'est la maîtresse divan
attal et vous êtes une comédienne non
professionnels voilà c'est ça votre vrai
métier ses secrétaires de rédaction
oui je travaille dans une maison
d'édition et entre autres je m'occupe
d'une revue qui s'appelle la revue car
la revue littéraire voilà et en fait
c'est une bonne idée d'avoir pris
quelqu'un qui n'était pas comédien parce
que ça donne du flou à votre personnage
vous êtes une espèce de fantasme peu non
là en fait quand j'ai écrit le scénario
je l'avais écrit ce personnage comme
c'était pas un personnage incarné au
scénario c'était quelqu'un c'était une
idée d'une autre vie quoi il ya beaucoup
à chaque fois que
vois que que je rencontrais une actrice
professionnelle enfin qu'on connaissait
elle venait avec un background toujours
on la connaissait et on connaissait ses
fils mais c'était c'était à côté du rôle
que chercher et puis j'ai eu la chance
de croiser angie et puis tout d'un coup
je me suis dit que je comprends voilà et
puis j'avais vu à côté de charlotte et
malgré
le fait qu'elle soit assez différente je
trouvais qu'il y avait elle avait une
chose en commun et ça me plaisait
voilà de tenter l'expérience
j'ai demandé à une vie de venir faire
une lecture et puis elle s'est prêtée au
jeu et elle est extraordinaire dans le
film hannah des scènes en plus
émotionnelle et pour quelqu'un qui ait
jamais fait ça je trouve qu'elle s'est
donnée à fond et je la trouve vraiment
vous êtes complètement craqué sur votre
maîtresse on va dire ça comme ça
professionnellement professionnellement
j'ai un cadeau pour toi c'est quoi c'est
un blouson parce qu'on libère va arriver
c'est un beau ces gens qui est si gentil
parce que la chaîne personnaliser leur
personnel
tu vois
je te rassure il est réversible yvan
oui d'accord à oui biensur d'un mode
arcade aux côtés si c'est d'ailleurs un
c'est pas bon
je te prête pour l'interview l'a
toujours pas là on peut essayer la
première question
ouais les y aller première question je
reviens sur vous tous souhaité après
lundi donc c'est l'interview complexe
d'actrice emmanuelle seigner est ce que
vous êtes déjà dix actrices finalement
c'est peut-être pas mon truc oui voilà
est ce que vous êtes déjà dit j'ai des
gros mollets non j'ai déjà dit j'aime
pas mes yeux
non
je vous ai déjà dit ça sont donc
s'effacer pas bien c'est complexe
d'actrice leur acheter pour toi départ
la match est pour lui
est ce que vous êtes déjà dit mais
qu'est ce qu'il me trouvera mam
est ce que vous êtes déjà dit ma soeur
m'a fait honte
si vous êtes déjà dit je suis jalouse de
charlotte non est ce que vous êtes déjà
dit j'aimerais quand même cette
interview elle est bien sa table je lui
ai déjà dit j'aimerais qu'on me filme
comme ivan film charlotte oui
en fait le salon
est ce que vous êtes déjà dit je
n'aurais jamais dos car c'est la honte
devant mon mari
non je vous ai déjà dit si ce qui ne
fait pas un carton j'arrête le cinéma
si vous êtes déjà dit la critique ne
m'aime pas oui est ce que vous êtes déjà
dit qu'elle compte laurent gerra oui
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu